hey 42 here more than a third of the
world's smokers are Chinese
welcome to rip
for every $1,000 of music sold the
average musician makes $23 40 of your
stomach acid got onto your skin it would
burn a hole in it three quarters of
French people take their annual holiday
in France Tokyo has three times as many
michelin-starred restaurants as Paris
many of the doves released at the
opening ceremony of the 1988 Seoul
Olympics were accidentally roasted alive
when the Olympic flame was lit during
World War two the Russians built a tank
that could fly one out of every 21 New
Yorkers is a millionaire electrons move
along an electricity cable about as fast
as honey flows before the Queen of
England puts her shoes on a member of
the royal household wears them first to
make sure they are comfortable every
year of thousand letters arrive in
Jerusalem addressed to God only three of
the original 60 clauses of the Magna
Carta are still in force in Italy 13 is
not an unlucky number but 17 is the
Netherlands exports more soya sauce than
Japan and not to each other as they pass
during the 1880s existed the 13 club
they formed to debug the superstitions
surrounding the number 13 during
meetings they were dined with 13 people
at the table and spilled salt on Friday
the 13 the club has had five US
presidents as members Chester Arthur
Grover Cleveland Benjamin Harrison
William McKinley and Theodore Roosevelt
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2